from the post-millennial we'll talk some
domestic politics my friends we are
entering we're entering the beginning
of the presidential cycle so you did
have a bunch of announcements we've seen
rallies but oh boy this is where things
start to heat up especially as we get
into the next several months when the
primary races are going to get hot
because early next year I believe is
when we're going to see all the primary
votes actually happen so the ads are
going to start popping up right now and
here's the latest Trump currently holds
a 39 lead among GOP voters Nationwide
what I find truly fascinating is the
rate at which Vivek ramaswamy is
skyrocketing they say with Trump at 59
descent is at 17 uh Vivek ramaswamy is
now at number three with eight percent
and Rising I'm curious what you guys
think I think Trump's got in the bag
I do think I would add to this in terms
of the democratic race it is fascinating
that there even is one
it should not be
the precedent for this is that Joe Biden
as president is just going to run again
there's no primary but there is a
primary
and get this
RFK Jr is polling higher comparably with
the Democrats than DeSantis is with the
Republicans that I find really
interesting it's not a one-for-one
correlation
but DeSantis as probably the leading
Republican politician in the country
like Trump's not in office right now and
there's nobody else who's got anything
close to him can't get that close to
Trump RFK is at 20 percent doing better
in the polls as a non-politician
presumably because of how bad Joe Biden
is doing which I find fascinating so how
are you feeling are you riding with
Biden oh yeah now that it is interesting
uh because I feel like there's not that
many people that have been uh I mean I
don't know when I hear what's I don't
even know how to pronounce his name yeah
I know what is what does Trump call him
I don't think he calls him anything
he didn't get a name yet oh okay okay we
think it's going to be Rama swampy yeah
when does Trump go to Chris and him but
but he's not he's not an establishment
guy so I don't know yeah I don't know
but I like the vacuum and I I think
I'm wondering if a vague ends up in
second place in the in the jupy primary
because the Dude if you've seen these
viral clips of him he is hitting it out
of the park yeah he's a bit talker
there's a viral clip where a woman
starts yelling about Republicans being
evil and a bunch of people get up start
yelling at her and he's like no no let
her come up let her come up let her
speak let her speak and he's like ma'am
I believe in the First Amendment please
say what you had to say are your mommy
say thank you for coming thank you for
sharing your thoughts and no man's like
crying and then she leaves the vague
knows how to handle this stuff Trump
knows how to handle the press in his way
Vivek knows how to handle them in a very
clean and tactful way so I'll be really
interested in in seeing what happens
um as time goes on because Vivek is
starting up he's starting to pick up
yeah yeah well one thing I appreciate
that's being acknowledged here is that
in order for any presidential candidate
to really be successful or worthwhile
they have to understand that the media
is their enemy and they have to know how
to combat them
well Donald Trump doesn't seem to get
that
he can use his enemy yeah he called the
fake press all day night but he keeps
giving him interviews and one-on-ones
and they secretly record him and then
link it to the government he gets
arrested for it come on well it's funny
he knows they're there he knows but I
think he also engages with this in such
a way that if they air footage of him
saying something he wishes they hadn't
recorded him saying he can just use it
exactly and then he can also call the
reporter a mean name or something and it
just ends up being way worse optically
for the person to release the audio true
true fair I'm really interested to see
how Vivek handles this stuff because
he's not a politician he's got no record
he has ideas I like his ideas I like his
attitude he was talking I saw one video
uh today where he was talking about how
he would end the war in Ukraine and I'm
like these are bold and direct
statements to make he said he would he
would have like an Armistice with Russia
where they would it would it would
divide the country like Korea he would
then demand in exchange for these
territories they cease their military
alliance with China because of how big a
threat that man China have become
especially with the brics Nations Etc
and I'm like typically sessions give
wishy-washy answers because they don't
want to be overtly directed to Vegas
just coming out and saying it I like
I've said this before uh I think that
Vivek is is nothing but a uh positive
addition I don't think that he has a
significant chance of actually being the
nominee but I do think that his position
on the debate stage is going to make a
lot of people
make commitments and and discuss topics
that yeah you know establishment
candidates would never touch and I think
that's extremely good what about VP
ramaswamy you think that could happen I
think so I don't the status is
impossible at this point they hate each
other too much yeah I think he's running
I think that's what he's kind of running
for is a position I don't feel like
Vivek really thinks he's he can win I
feel like he's running for to and he has
to he can't admit that I mean obviously
sure okay no no obviously not no um but
I think that he's running for you know a
positioning cabinet or maybe VP or
something like that but he's running to
to you know raise his star in in DC and
and I do think that he's got a good
argument and there's good reasons for
him to be running and I so I think it's
a you know positive I think a trump RFK
a trump Kennedy ticket and hits it out
of the park yeah I think you would see
tremendous margins yeah with RFK pulling
20 in the on the Democrat side if Trump
was like I'm gonna give you guys the guy
you wanted he could theoretically Paul
let's just say half of that let's say
half of the Democrats polled in favor of
of okay that's 10 percent of democrat
voters voted for Trump uh Trump wins no
no question well it's it's interesting
right because I've mentioned some of my
issues with RFK in the past that said he
has the Kennedy name he he's he has this
unique advantage of having a dynastic
name well also being anti-establishment
I like that word I mean it is he he's
got he's part of this political family
he's a Kennedy he's not just a total
Outsider in the sense that the American
people have no reason to be familiar
with him but he also is an outsider in
the ways that are meaningful to the
American people
yeah true he's got a bunch of dumb
tweets don't get me wrong I mean he he
was like what did he call the
anti-terrorist or something yeah I like
people are sharing that stuff I like but
I'm not bothered by it yeah and look I I
just like I said I disagree with him on
a lot uh I wouldn't vote for him as a
candidate but that said he does have
this unique Advantage I'll acknowledge
that I don't know I might vote in the
Democrat primaries and and for RFK I
mean I I like the idea of I think an RFK
leadership in the Democratic Party
forcefully realigns it in in a in a
positive way for this country uh I think
again I I would I would agree with that
in a sort of cautious way like I said
there's a lot RFK believes in that I
think is really bad but when you look at
how awful the Democratic party is right
now he would absolutely be an
improvement that's what I'm saying I'm
like yeah even if RFK on a scale of
negative to 100 to positive 100 is it
negative 10 negative 10 is a huge I
agree no I agree with you democrat party
I totally agree with you reluctantly
yeah and so you know I was talking about
Trump in 2020 and my and and I've had
these Libertarians be like what are you
really going to vote for the lesser of
two evils and I'm like I don't think
Trump's evil I I give him a net positive
score I mean the foreign policy was
tremendous that's because it's a
libertarian's perspective like they're
expecting you to see things like Liberty
exactly exactly like I think it's
because it's the archaic view of the two
parties but Trump was an Insurgent who
came in with a different perspective
well also and uh dude when people say
that to me it's like so I should vote
for the lesser of three evils and pick
your candidate I don't like the
libertarian either yeah yeah sometimes I
will but I I like the libertarian party
I like the Mrs caucus where is their
announcement come on guys what's going
on where who who's running with the
Democrats the Republicans are in full
swing the Libertarians got to get going
hmm I don't know I like a Libertarian
party but come on I don't know if
they're gonna have a candidate why do
you think because they because no one's
announced there was talking about Dave
Smith well there yeah exactly there was
talk about Dave but I don't think that
Dave's gonna do it I this is just a Vibe
I haven't I have no inside information
or anything but he if he was gonna
announce I feel like he would have
announced already yeah I agree so and
and you know it wouldn't be this koi if
wishy-washy maybe stuff yeah it would be
like we're in full swing we we'd at the
very least be be seeing him do more do
more yep because right before everybody
announces they start ramping things up
you can see the gears in motion and
we're like oh it looks like they're
gonna it's like even around to sandus
they were like next week it's gonna
happen then rumors circulated then
sources say and then finally he
announced we've got nothing from the
libertarian so far but but what I was
saying about Trump in 2020 is like you
know look I'm looking at him uh the
school choice
I'm in favor of
I'm looking at his Banning the wokeness
in Government Contracting because it
violates the Civil Rights Act a group
that and foreign policy I thought it was
fantastic and so I'm like I'm not
looking at Trump as a lesser of two
evils I'm looking at him as like a small
net positive no new Wars
withdrawal withdrawal from Afghanistan
Abraham Accords massively net positive
so I'm like if you were to do the Trump
presidential quotient and took all of
the different elements of of the
presidency there's a lot of different
categories where Trump is negative and
there's a lot where he's positive that
leads us to on a scale of minus 100 to
100 Trump might be in a six and I'm like
so I'm not here to praise the man and
scream he's the greatest guy who ever
lived in the god Emperor or anything
like that I'm just like you know I Get
Enough from it I don't feel like I'm
voting for a negative I feel like the
foreign policy stuff was was good for us
and there are of course some some
negative areas but overall we got a
great economy I can't blame the
president for covid I can criticize him
for his policies uh lockdown support in
the beginning I can criticize him for uh
not firing fauci but look I got to say
this at the time I didn't know better
better either thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time